and I have to say that if I was in the
White House I was in the Obama
administration I would not be
comfortable with how the last three days
went today was day three of the hearings
on the Patient Protection Affordable
Care Act also known as Obamacare today
there were two big questions that the
supreme court was addressing the first
is an issue called severability if the
individual mandate which compels every
American buyer secure health insurance
is struck down by the court does the
rest the entire Act have to fall as well
the second issue that was addressed
today was the laws Medicaid expansion so
Medicaid is the joint federal-state
program providing health care for the
poor and what the challengers were
arguing here was that although the
states had voluntarily once upon a time
entered into this program the government
by forcing them to expand the Medicaid
program was was unlawfully using its
spending power essentially the
government was coercing the state's my
big takeaway from today is that if the
individual mandate is ruled
unconstitutional the entire health care
law is likely to go down as well this is
particularly do I think and this is
often the case with the Supreme Court
how is Justice Kennedy going to vote
just as Kennedy's big concern today was
basically the issue of judicial
restraint would the Supreme Court be
overstepping its its powers its judicial
powers by striking down the entire law
or would it in fact be overstepping its
powers by just picking and choosing
which parts of the health care law to
uphold and strike down in Kennedy's
position it seemed to me and he
expressed this in several ways was that
in fact the more restrained thing that
the Supreme Court could do would be to
strike down the entire law and the
argument along these lines would be by
giving Congress half the law given
Congress this sort of shell you take out
the individual mandate and then you
leave these other pieces that's a mess
and in fact that's something the court
shouldn't be doing what the court should
do the modest thing the restrained thing
for the courts do would be to strike
down the whole law now that we've
concluded the three days of arguments
this point the decision it's in the
hands of the court we have to wait and
see we expect a ruling the end of June
at the end of the term this is typically
what the Supreme Court does they save
the biggest the blockbuster decisions
for for the last week maybe the last day
and I have to say that if I was in the
White House if I was in the Obama
ministration I would not be comfortable
with how the last three days what that
doesn't mean that the administration is
going to lose it doesn't mean that the
mandates going down but I think the
administration had reason to be more
confident going in and they have to be
very concerned with how it went and I
don't just mean that the Solicitor
General had a bad day I mean that their
arguments we're nowhere near as strong
as they thought they were going to be
and that the justices and not just ones
who are obviously conservative like you
know Scalia or a lido but but swing
Justice Kennedy poked real holes and
have real fundamental concerns with what
the government was arguing and if I was
in the White House I would be concerned
about that